[Musique]
tu diras ce que tu voudras Fredo mais
dans cet allé grro ben on retrouve
encore vachement l'influence
d'Amar faut dire que c'est la période
charnière de l'évolution betoven ou je
sais bien mais avou que c'est plus
sensible dans laro que dans la dagio
c'est eniligrane quoi par le fait c'est
sa deuxème manière à bine dans le
premier thème il fait un large exposé
alors forcément dans
op quand le premier violon et le violon
ils attaquent à l'unisson et ben on sent
déjà que ça va s'épanouir en
contrepoint tu as raison tu sais comme
le disait de la croix dans le béau des
coiturs on respire déjà la mélancolie
qui trahit un feu intérieur je l' pas vu
cel avec son
SC de
Rouin pas vrai